[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con a mediados
de mayo el tribunal supremo de justicia
de venezuela ejecutó la medida de
embargo contra la sede del diario 'el
nacional' en caracas para indemnizar por
supuestos daños morales al dirigente
chavista diosdado cabello quien demandó
al periódico en 2015 por replicar una
nota del abs de españa' y the wall
street journal en la que el número 2 del
partido socialista fue vinculado con
narcotráfico la noticia dejó sin piso a
este medio de comunicación que se ha
caracterizado en los últimos años por
ser un espacio de oposición vamos a
conversar con su director miguel
henrique otero quien se exilió en españa
miguel gracias por acompañarnos y
bienvenido a france 24 cuéntenos la
publicación de 'el nacional' que mereció
la denuncia de diosdado cabello en 2015
no fue sólo de ustedes otros 80 diarios
del continente también replicaron la
noticia ustedes sostienen este reportaje
hay aquí un caso flagrante de violación
a la libertad de prensa
por supuesto es esa nota fue publicada
en el 2015 y que era una nota que salió
por todas las agencias noticiosas cuando
a veces española publicó el hecho de que
un fiscal federal del estado de nueva
york estaba investigando a diosdado
cabello por sus vinculaciones con el
narcotráfico nos decía que él era
narcotraficante y distancia no
investigado esa otra salió por la
agencia la publicaron 80 periódicos
porque diosdado cabello era el
presidente de la asamblea nacional de
venezuela de una noticia importante él
introdujo esta demanda de información
nunca nunca demandó a abc porque sabía
que ese nunca gana eso no va a progresar
en españa y él dos años después la dea
le remitió una orden de captura por oro
por narcotráfico adeudado cabello y una
recompensa de 10 millones de dólares a
quién
le permita a la de capturar bueno eso de
por sí es una confirmación de la noticia
para que la dea haya hecho eso pues
evidentemente no tenían que estar
investigando entonces la información se
cae por su propio peso veo además de eso
es a esa demanda nunca prosperó pero
introdujo una demanda civil y la demanda
civil es la que llegó al tribunal
supremo de justicia nos aplican esta
sentencia que no sabemos de dónde la
sacan de 13 millones de dólares la puso
el propio diosdado porque en venezuela
los jueces actúan según las
instrucciones del ejecutivo y antes de
que se hicieran procedimientos legales
para cobrar ese dinero
el periódico fue tomado por la guardia
nacional asaltado por la guardia
nacional como armas largas sacaron a la
calidad escrita ha tomado en una
ocupación ilegal del periódico de la de
la sede del periódico lo cual era un
atropello que no tiene nombre
miguela direcciones concretas que se
estén adelantando para recuperar la sede
del nacional
la verdad es que el tribunal supremo es
la última el último camino en cualquier
país para apelar no se puede apelar una
decisión al igual supremo lo que estamos
apelando es la cantidad de
irregularidades que están detrás del
juicio pero aquí en las apelamos para la
fiscalía explicarles que hicieron este
atropello a la defensoría del pueblo
todos son todos en venezuela son
empleados del ejecutivo y siguen obtener
el ejecutivo lo que quiere decir es que
lo más probable es que ilegalmente sea
por los caminos legales en venezuela no
podemos hacer nada entonces vamos a ir a
las instancias internacionales
las ideas que las naciones unidas-
etcétera que ya ellos tienen el caso ya
lo tienen y están horrorizados todos
todos los juristas los cuales serán
presentados en frutas horrorizados de
cómo se hizo inclusive ahí el bloque
constitucional de venezuela no están
todos los presidentes de todas las
asociaciones de abogados de todos los
estados están todos los entes
constitucionalistas y los demás
todos han firmado una una declaratoria
diciendo que ese juicio es absolutamente
ilegal y ha roto con todos los
mecanismos constitucionales para un
wichi miguel y muchas gracias por
acompañarnos aquí en france24 para
hablar sobre el diario 'el nacional' que
también ha enfrentado muchos golpes
durante la último ante los últimos años
por ser precisamente un medio de
oposición en venezuela
muchas gracias nuevamente por
acompañarnos esto es cinco minutos con
quédense con nosotros
[Música]